i like making funny noises in bed
meaning
like when i get up i'll go like no
so you like when it's warm you don't
you're not like ooh cold weather
bianca the reason i like
warm weather yes is
because i have what's known in the
business as
bad circulation i'm not one of those
white
people who wear shorts in february wow
like i'm always cold um i'm
almost always cold and then i have and
then
and that's i've been like i thought i
was like a [ __ ] and then i remembered
when i was a little kid you know when
you pull your sleeves in
yeah that was like my logo as a kid is
me
with no with my arms in my so i guess
i'm
not a [ __ ] i guess i've been a [ __ ]
you know that's per
every guy i've ever ever been with is
runs so hot and i'm
there's no cold guys out there there's
one but it's
it's cold it's [ __ ] it's right
underneath the whole time and it was
freezing
every time i leave i'm like i gotta get
out of here it's freezing cold in your
house
yeah well that i also think it's a white
black thing what do you mean
white people will like think it's brisk
like it's 69 70 right they love it
apparently there was a whole plot on
career enthusiasm
where like a a runner in a season where
when jb smooth lived with larry he kept
turning the thermostat up to
79 which when i heard about it i laughed
out loud
which is so [ __ ] fun so true
so funny on the heat yeah and
so are you you're blind so i like it 73
in my house
when i'm in when i check into a hotel
i'll put it 76
i'm eighty eighty eighteen that's crazy
eighty just
a constant ai eighty with the breeze is
like
eight what's the breeze so i'll put on
my heater
and then i'll turn on the fan all right
just creating my my co-host little
ecosystem
a little eco um the uh
yeah the they i like it warm do you
don't you don't like when it's rains you
know most people
no i don't understand this no ireland
like well you would
i don't wan i want tropical weather all
the time
but you don't go outside because it's
not it's not warm enough but you live in
why even live in venice because
venice is colder i agree but hollywood
has
nothing but [ __ ] creeps and pieces of
[ __ ]
uh lamert park's open totally it sounds
black to me sounds a little blacker than
i like
baldwin hills black hollywood yeah but
that's i don't like the location i
i don't i want to move but i don't know
where to it's i've been trying to help
you and i
feel like you're interested well i
didn't give you enough love when you
sent me the first batch
that was a lot it was a lot and i it was
overwhelming there were a few like there
was a few winners in there
you know we're gonna run a contest buy
neal a new house
pick neal's new house and i have to i
have to and you have to oh
that is new whatever the price is
what it's an arranged marriage what is
a house yeah if you know how arranged
marriages work better than real
marriages
yeah i would just i would i would grow
to love it
wherever i lived over a certain price
you're gonna love it
yeah is it gonna be it's giant and nice
it's nice you're not gonna be like oh
not even me who can go uh about ah
i um the golden globes were last night
yeah
and i didn't i saw some highlights today
um and they didn't work well tina and
amy
at the top was not was kind of choppy
well they were in different yeah which
is like just don't do it or
i i mean they were they have a deal to
do it for a couple years so they did
what did they make fun of
that i was like oh
that see a movie
movie that was really funny uh
they they said yeah sia's movie
music is nominated for the biggest
flopperino
like they just went in on the literally
quote-unquote flop arena
laporino it was it was so fun i was like
i felt my face doing and you you went
autistic when you heard about it you
turned into the character music
and you had do musicals
not gonna do that to me but it was they
talked about how
bad the movie was in the opening wow
uh see is it uh if you don't know
c made a movie called music and
she did it was about an autistic
child who who she the girl from dance
moms
dance moms and um
[Music]
kate hudson plays mom and this girl has
hallucinations where
she's or she's autistic right she's
autistic but she
is not an autistic girl so she went so
the problem was the actress
wasn't autistic yes and
it's it's like again
it's not i don't want to get into like
it's wokeness gone awry but
it's it just makes it clear that like
wokeness
it's just you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
if you try to play their game of
inc like the all thing and then it's and
then to be a good movie on top of that
and this and like the stack of things it
has to be
is incredibly difficult and then they
don't give you the benefit of the doubt
um the problem is so i disagree with you
i think it's
i think it's comic rules like you can't
make fun of it
if you aren't somehow attached to it
you know well i have a number of race
jokes that are pretty good
right but you're they're also so good it
either has to be
undeniably amazing so crazy good so
crazy good or you have to be i remember
i watched there was like some
kill tony i was working and a guy got up
there
and just made fun of breast cancer i
remember
i think i told you that yeah i remember
thinking but the
who said if maybe it was sinbad or
somebody made that point
like you aren't a breast cancer survivor
so it feels
really you make everyone feel bad in the
audience to laugh at what you're saying
because
we don't feel like we can yeah there's
no like is this cool
if you were a breast cancer survivor
then it's like okay we can laugh with
you so i think it's
the wokeness like how
so how what
it's autistic so an autistic person has
to write i mean it's just how much
autism do you need
in the in the inclusion was there any
person but the thing is she's
so in the movie that there were these
dance numbers and they were supposed
to represent an episode like a sensory
kind of episode and so then i went to
some
um the times i've had autism that's not
i'll check out gosh
so i follow i started looking at the
reviews from these um
kind of instagrams run by people with
autism um
high functioning you know what i mean
like they could have
had hold on we're getting a call oh
ding dong from a
golden globe participant people think i
don't know nobody take your mask off
who is that what's that now
daniel kahluya everybody
i'm not you're not going to catch
anything from me take off your mask
yeah where are you i'm just i'm just i
don't know i'm in my house
you're in your house you know it's funny
you know what
a uh relaxing give me the phone okay you
know what
um winning a golden globe should
automatically get you the vaccine shot
of your choices
wait i have one question for black
reasons
for black reasons you can't conform or
deny that you want the
the vaccine for black reasons bro
all the black
no i know you're you're right you're
smart you're getting very political
wait i have one question one has one
question what is your question all right
okay how many daniel kahluas does it
take to work a microphone
because your mic was out oh yeah you're
i didn't see it did you hit mute who
[ __ ] up your audio
i don't know who did that like that
wasn't me i was just living my life
oh you were all right i was i was how
could
like the person that's getting you like
the person that's waiting to receive the
award or not shouldn't be the person
that takes the mic
yeah that shouldn't really be your
responsibility responsibility
i think someone's saying like i didn't
put them and i'm like that's not my
like so i have to go on mute it's like
there's a whole this is nb
what what what station is it nbc you
know yeah
like someone's got our music you know
and why is it on
me i like i played a little bit listen
i played an activist let someone else
like
yeah you shouldn't have to you gotta
mute yours on you yourself too
yeah i did my job so i'm thinking you
know let's like let's share the load
here
you say i don't know this balance it ah
say because it's a lot on my shoulders
isn't it to just unmute
just your unmute just so that's a lot of
pressure yeah
kind of moments yeah so it's what but i
know i know i can't even say anything
like that but yeah yeah shout me offline
yeah all right i'll hit you i'll hit you
later offline but
online yeah [ __ ] matrix this [ __ ] is
crazy
yeah yeah some other [ __ ] it's
everywhere but no mad love yeah all
right
long life long life long life that's
great what a good wasn't that a good
[ __ ] that was a great surprise guess
what neil surprises this guy you know
what i mean
is that our last and only surprise well
i've invited another
um relevant
hollywood figure wow neil like comes
back with a mustache
hello it's norjo
uh a relevant hollywood figure this week
um but
uh i mean not whatever like it's like
it's a big week for people
it is it's certain people it's a big
week for them and i wanted one of them
to come on and talk about it
just quickly um i so i didn't see the
golden globes was he muted the whole
time
well he started right and he goes like
right right and then laura dern is like
ooh okay oh unfortunately daniel has
some technical difficulties
and we just we wish him the best and
then
he goes like wait you do me you did my
day
no you did me die and then they let him
do his speech
but like they were like walking like
laura dern left
they were moving on and then he was like
no [ __ ]
oh god let me do my like it was that's
great it was done
and then he was like no i'm doing my
speech what the [ __ ] not my fault
it's hard you wouldn't know it as an
american but he's from uh
he's like he's like from
council estates he's not which is the
the hood it's the project but americans
will be like well he must be royalty oh
yeah americans
with that accent nigerian prince yeah
like what
um i'll say this for kaluya who i know
he was a champs fan and we just had
lunch one day
uh and now he comes to the store pretty
often
good tipper right good guy great great i
don't disclose but
great he's in the don't do oh you that's
right you don't off the air she'll tell
me
um
um he is uh but he's a good dude and
the thing in that movie you know what
his a lot of his appeal is
he's got perfectly symmetrical eyes
he's got like a nice face [ __ ]
smooth skin he's got really sweet eyes
and how deep was when lunch it was it
turned into dinner
um uh and there was dicks
it was dicks dicks were served uh no
he's got like really
[ __ ] nice yeah they catch the light
yeah and that's exactly right like in a
way that you if you met him you'd be
like i don't know
and then when you certain people you see
on camera and you're like
what what in the [ __ ] um
but it's sad that people have to wear
masks
inside it's like that's how from council
estates he is
he's still he's doesn't trust me he
don't trust him
that's very funny that he can't say that
he he likes or dislikes the
vaccine i know but he's not wrong
right people just jump on you or
whatever he's alright so it's like just
don't say anything
yeah just say nothing um the golden
globes were
uh awkward because usually they'll show
the five
six and then when i win it's like
and then it zooms into me but it just
still showed everyone
so they were like during the uh during
their speeches during other people's
speeches
yeah really it was so bad
it was good for like thank you jesus for
this morsel of entertainment but it
wasn't
good for the show so somebody won and i
think
maybe it was amanda's secret i don't
know they were still on camera so
she was like and thank you to all my
fellow like nominees and they were like
yeah it was fake like obviously they
didn't mean it
it was just like you're still on
even though you're disappointed it was
just it was just funny
it was funnier than it's like i don't
know
and then they're all in their living
rooms and yeah then you start thinking
did we need
the awards i don't i watched the
half of tina and amy's monologue and i
was like just
don't do the [ __ ] i mean like we
celebrities won't be here but first
responders are here and now you're at
risk
it just seemed like well are they
outside are they doing anything to
mitigate the risk for these people
um and uh i don't
i couldn't tell no i will say they
weren't spreading
um uh aerosol through laughter though
from what i could see they weren't a
great crowd
um but you know that's not what they're
there for they're for um
because they're heroes well yeah and
then some of them why okay
you're you're you're a tv guy uh why
is comedy and musicals in the same
[ __ ] country because it's the
hollywood foreign press
and it's from what i understand it's
it's a fake organization
like it's there's 86 it's lit
no it's all press
from not america and they just figured
out a way
oh globes no but the hollywood foreign
press that's who gives it away
so it's the foreign press so they're
not like they're not legitimate but they
they give it away for
uh a little bit
fishy reasons oh yeah well i'm wondering
did they give it tv again because
sandberg won for brooklyn nine-nine and
i wanted to say like
i'll give you all uh a hundred bucks if
you can name his character
on brooklyn nine-nine the golden globes
seems they're weird
they're weird there's weird reasons for
every they
and then they had this one part where it
looked like a
like a tim and eric special it was a
german
and a lady from india and someone else
from
i forgot sorry and they were like we are
doing everything to be
inclusive and we haven't gone far enough
and it's like they just did this thing
basically saying we're
the problems we have not brought in
enough black people yeah and we're
really sorry
but it was it's still in this
box of a superficial
awards ceremony you know what i mean so
enough it feels
feels authentic at all it just is it was
in the in a meta way it was very funny
but it was not
it was just awkward seems awkward it's
just
i i just seem like like his point like
it's it would be better if it were
a like not he could be married
and you want the approval of hot women
live
and women want to look be glamorous and
desirable
on a red carpet with human bodies
looking at them
so the point of it it just all seems so
forced
and and unnecessary well and
now no shade to my international folks
but
we raised in this country is very very
complicated
and not to me because okay um
but uh when you go outside this country
it's it can be 1955 in a lot of places
you know
in terms of judgment on black people
immigration process 1995 in most of
america and then
in certain parts of the world it's 1655
[Music]
like not even it's just like i
i don't even get mad at the racism i
experienced traveling it's like no you
black girl
there it's like this so
like i'm not gonna fight all these
people you know what i mean it's very
it's it's so um i guess there's a lot of
ignorant
like what we would call ignorance around
the world that i
i'm not surprised when we look at the
nominees of the hollywood foreign press
like it's not diverse it's really
it's it really the funny thing is it's
gonna be hard
i guess francis mcdormand won last night
but i was gonna say it's gonna be hard
for a white person
to win just see for a while for the next
five years gonna be hard for
what it got harder you know the nominees
weren't
established last year they were savages
this year and it was only one
it was all white still oh is the whole
thing is white
the whole thing that's why it was like
god bless you for holding firm
stay and then they're like we really
need to change it's like you can't you
had a year
to do to now we're just announcing we
should start
i don't care but i'm not surprised that
that was the nominees of the hollywood
foreign press yeah
it's just like you know whatever i don't
want to talk [ __ ] but
yeah i get that um it's yeah it's
it's it's uh well what about the oscars
did they come out yet
the nominees they better hurry up though
isn't it soon
literally in two weeks oh maybe they did
maybe they did they must have
i don't i didn't know announced
shortlists announced what are they
didn't they move it up to february guys
it's march 1st
you guys [ __ ] up you guys missed your
own death i i went to the last oscars
the last real oscars just so everyone
knows
nobody knows um did keenan do
pierre carr escargot no and i i didn't
watch enough
i look up keenan thompson pierre as
cargo
pierre's cargo is hilarious did you
oh my god all that tea is so much better
than
give me if he did give me
my flowers give me my [ __ ] give me
some money
and give him my flowers here's story
pierre escargo
first year of all that
uh okay this is kind of how life works
and show business so i'm working
for a casting director on singled out
right
yes um yes and we
i'm partially responsible for bringing
jenny mccarthy into our lives
and next door just in the office
um so i was working with the casting
director all the writers on
singled out quit still don't know why
really i mean
it's because of bad show but they
whatever um
i was then promoted to writer's
assistant but there were no writers
wait all of them quit yeah this is on
the pilot
so i wrote on the pilot
for singled out next door
was a sketch show star a kid's sketch
show
and in the office was uh dan schneider
and brian robbins who had been on the
sitcom head of the class in the 80s and
90s so i recognized whatever
started talking to dan schneider about
sketches
at that point i think i need i knew jay
moore who was on sorry live
whatever um long story short
they're like do you want to pitch for
our show because we're
building we're creating a writing staff
uh
i said yes and i pitched
i was 20 and i pitched
a sketch called this maybe our other
special guest
nope god damn it um uh
i picked when i was like 20 or 21 i
pitched
a guy named who taught spanish named
paco delicious
oh god okay delicious
i don't get the job okay
then but two buddies of mine get the job
and they tell me about prs cargo and i'm
like
huh okay that's interesting it basically
he took it
and made it friends made it french and
but here's the punchline hired me the
next year
so is it satisfying enough or is it like
no well you know it's me it's nothing
satisfying enough roll the decks of
it put it on my grievance give me my
pots
[Music]
thank you well the [ __ ] will was on
top of it wasn't even
worn it's almost like if you just pay
attention to the show you can have the
sound effects right now don't give them
a call
it's a double it's again played give me
my pods again
at yourself just play it for yourself
there you go that's just for you
um and so
so give me my flowers and put my
flowers in my pots put my pierre escargo
uh so i want to smell my flowers put
them on my pockets did we have a
confrontation with dan at
any point about this no we never really
talked about it
um but it's fine does it happen
or is it kind of if that doesn't happen
no that's [ __ ] up okay that's like
demonstrably wrong like no that's
absolutely wrong like if someone sends
in
their work if they're pit or they're
like that doesn't happen very
you it legally it's too dicey
well yeah 20 21 year old kid so i if we
send
if i if you're going out for a job and
you send in a writing package or like
whatever they ask you to do right yeah
and they
don't hire you but you see your writing
okay
here's the issue with that they
sometimes they won't hire you
and another writer pitches the sketch
on your staff what do you do wait sorry
no what do you mean uh i
pitch let's say i pitch paco delicious
uh-huh
and then my buddies kevin and heath who
got the job
pitch paco delicious but not
literally pocketable but a similar
premise yeah they don't know what i
pitched
so is the show then prevented from doing
their sketch
okay because that happens all the time
like i told you a joke before we started
rolling
that you were like yeah i did it on
saturday it [ __ ] crushed so
is someone could someone else write it
yeah
but so i don't think they're a thief
though but
if you send in something and then you
say like for example
in in um commercial editions
that happens a lot actually where i'll
see somebody say something like
i is there was somebody said something
that i was like if i'm
i was going to get his venmo or her
venmo
from my casting directory to see if i
could just
give them money well because a lot of
times you know there's like a
trend where people are like don't improv
in those commercials
in the commercial editions because they
won't hire you but they will take your
cool little like button you put
and you'll see it end up on the
commercial so
is that do i get a writing credit you
don't i don't but if i direct it
you're kind of [ __ ] up you get eighty
dollars i'm kidding no you're good but
why not just hire me
you know uh because somebody else is
better looking that's right so that's
what it is it's like
it's better energy better you know
whatever but we like the thing you said
better eyes better kinder eyes mind you
i i book things so it's not personal
i'm just saying especially
um so didn't i just wanted that
grievance i had to air that grievance
okay
um what else just keep going and
and that i that daniel called in so
that's good that's taken care of
damn and uh and
what else i didn't but yeah it just
seemed like just give it
give it a second with the award shows i
i know that they want to
be funny if they did two years in one
year and it was like you just yeah
it's a tough tough competition sorry you
know daniel you're not even getting
nominated
um did you see black massage
yeah the you know my my hardest time i
had with it was not comparing it to
malcolm x
interesting like there were points where
it just you're just br my brain just
goes to malcolm x and is doing like
what the death like malcolm's
assassination day
sequence versus theirs like it was just
you can't it's impossible not to it's
impossible nazi but it
you it's not gonna make you like the
movie more no i will say
compares favorably in a lot of instances
right and i it wasn't a blowout meaning
it's like one isn't way better than the
other
i i like how
unforgiving judas is the whole time not
judas but you know whatever
on uh on on repentant you mean like yeah
what's his face um
yeah he just was like i'm uh in this for
me
like i gotta i gotta do this and
you didn't see as much um internal
struggle
as you'd think there would be that
somebody pointed out that the
fbi guy had more struggle than lakeith
that would make sense because i did
wonder how because it was
years with these people yeah you know
and years
in it and fighting for it and actually
seemed like he did
kind of believe they did a dream they
did a dream sequence they
did they did [ __ ] enough i actually
thought it was great i just assumed the
guy was
more just like some people no matter
what just because of the way his life
ended
you think he was conflicted well no not
that i just mean some people are
sometimes regardless of morals or were
they
and where they what their orientation is
or what their world view is sometimes
they're like i'm in this for me i'm
gonna go to jail if i don't do this
so i think that's what i care about so i
just thought that was
the true kind of struggle with fbi guys
just like
whatever's going to get me out of
trouble yeah i had an idea
for a uh
like a completely unrepentant
that's what people love about hannibal
actor yeah of course he's the greatest
because he just
he's like eight people and was like all
right well i'm gonna get out of here
this movie's over i'm gonna go i'm
literally does a sketch ending like i'm
gonna go
right i'm meeting an old friend for
dinner he literally has a [ __ ] sketch
ending line
i'm meeting an old friend for dinner and
then walks away and you're like [ __ ]
i love him but like a guy
like it's just that narcissists never
learn anything
right they don't [ __ ] learn anything
they go they their last thoughts are
like i was great at this
i wish he was a little more narcissistic
i think
the keith yes well yeah if he had just
been like nah
i mean he would have had to be like don
king
but yeah it would have been enjoyable uh
but though the movie was really good and
it was
pretty and honestly his scenes that he
had to do
those long speeches filling daniel yeah
that was
he did great with that that was like fun
to do
once you memorize those once you once
the nerves of like
let me be prepared once you memorize
those lines
like you're [ __ ] that's a
like you're [ __ ] like really
that's a fun scene to do also not so few
people get to do that
talk to a crowd and have them hang out i
know it's acting but even
no way in the middle it's gonna feel
very yeah it works
that's what i'm saying human right it's
like
that's way better than even if they're
on his close-up
and they were like should we clear out
they actually probably like yeah
no no no no no no and you know not being
from this country
and it being like fred hampton i that's
so much pressure
and the fact that he did it is like
impressive they should have the only
scene i would have added was
a 21st birthday scene at the beginning
of the movie because you
can't believe he's 21. you forget yeah
but you know um so
so there you go so um covet is
flat so we're moving it
pack your bags we're moving on uh covets
flat
in a bad way it's plateauing at like an
insanely high number
seven around seventy thousand a week or
seventy thousand a day
of infection and because people think
we're done this is the pro i mean
this is where human beings are
impossible because on the one hand i'm
like we're kind of done
yeah and on the other hand i'm like
we're not
what are you guys doing on the other
hand putting your mask on in your house
everybody's got senioritis
yeah with with covid and they're they're
you know who it's going to kill
ironically enough seniors
um but the uh i don't even know what to
make of it other than
it's don't do don't give people covet
yeah i mean the nice thing is now
i think the vaccine pool is way bigger
so if you were going to well the numbers
on scene actually ironically enough
seniors is down
like off a cliff yeah in terms of death
and even
infection i think um now it's just meat
packers which is great
which i'm excited okay do you see that
john oliver yeah again i was gonna post
it and write
like i know you guys love your meat
is this a reason oliver did a long
uh story about just how
awful the working conditions are at
meatpacking plants
before covet and then covid makes it
just
even worse and it's like guys eh you're
still
like sorry bro okay now
you're i realize everything i watch ends
up
in me being a piece of [ __ ] now
everything i
every documentary i'm like so huh didn't
see that one coming
i literally listened to a audio
uh article from the new york times about
the points guy the guy who just freaking
fliers
and then at the end it ends up i'm the
piece of [ __ ]
somehow i'm a pc because i have an
uh a premium credit card that works with
points
and what happens is they raise the price
everywhere else
in stores to cover the cost of the
credit card fee
and poor people pay the price so that
that is the story of how
i'm a piece of [ __ ] um
but yeah it's it's uh meat packers are
still getting pumped you know what i
my takeaway is not yours is meat eaters
eh
mine is white people wash your [ __ ]
meat
it's disgusting the guy pissed right
where he was standing and continued to
dice up the chicken and your people
would just throw it in a pot
give him my pots
it's appropriate it works
[Music]
um so yeah
the reason i became a vegetarian in the
first place is because i it's
bad for people the meat industry is bad
for people
i don't care about animals especially
padre does
find a reason people that are like sorry
bro yeah just find a reason
the problem is though it's how the big
meat industries are run because i have
friends who are they
they're part of the black farmers union
and they have little
plots of land where they do these small
farms
um around california and the
that meat is fresh and that meat is not
impacting you know the environment like
like the major industry is you know what
i mean yeah so there is a way
if you to eat meat i just it's a premium
you want to pay a premium to eat
like low-impact meat on the environment
yeah but it's that's still the
it that uh ignores the carbon
from their from the methane from their
farts no matter how you raise them
right well then wouldn't that just be
the green that's the greenhouse gas from
the meat industry is farting which is
of course it's all but there's other
issues with
of course that goes out saying it's the
funniest thing that ever happened
but that cow farts are going to kill us
i
why cowboys are not human like why is it
because they
what they eat and how they digest it and
interesting maybe although maybe they've
just never measured
what come what human farts consists of
guys come on bye
um so covered rest in power kang
speaking of rest in power king tiger
woods
tiger king somebody did a very
buddy of mine did a very simple joke
come on
every once in a while tiger likes to
remind us that he is asian
stupid just a very simple joke i don't
want to say who wrote it because i don't
want him to get
any kind of cancelled or even
inconvenienced
um but it's a yeah i won't say
um the yeah tiger woods has now
jumped out of
he's jumped the the greek shark
meaning the shark the sharkarus
he's jumped the uh shark shark
sharkilopolis
because he was his life was a greek
tragedy
right he's like [ __ ] prodigy and then
he gets
it's a sex addict whatever um
and then he would get to his wife in an
accident and fall from grace and all
that stuff like
greek tragedy then he gets better
and gets into a car accident at seven in
the morning it's like that's just
[ __ ] no that doesn't work plot-wise
it doesn't mean anything it's just like
wow neil you're even like
critical of [ __ ] of life that's bad
writing
um it's bad writing like my dreams are
bad writing horrible writing
what do you mean what do you dream about
i pretty much every night
somebody lauren michaels is mad at me
that's my dream
five nights a week weird i've had it
before i
knew him before i ever worked at the
entire livestream for a week no because
it's
un it's something embarrassing about it
it's so embarrassing it's so
embarrassing i did it on twitter that
like i think dreams are stupid because
most of my dreams are like charlie
chaplin's mad at you
and that's funny and
true-ish but it's way more specific to
the point where
i woke up yesterday morning i was like i
had another snl dream
like it's crazy what about when you
actually worked on snl i'm sure i had
snl dreams
did is it worse or is it just study no
then i have mad tv
it's weird um no it just makes no sense
and i've had it
for so long my and they're not
what they're just i'm usually in joe's
office
or seth's office they they they
same office and somebody's mad at me
it's lauren
and i just hear the rumor and then and
then it's morning is it
crippling like anxiety no it's just like
[ __ ] or it's sometimes i have a good
point it's stupid
it's literally just my grievances in
in in dream form they've just taken the
form of a lawyer yeah
it means it's just general work anxiety
at a job i don't have and when i do have
it i'm decent at it
right so it doesn't make sense that's
really that's why
the brain is stupid uh so tiger woods
obviously heal and power kang
um the all the players for red shirts is
cute
kind of cute for what for tiger all the
golfers
oh he's bored yeah his target outfit his
yeah but his
his is blood red so
it's a different kind of different thing
um it's platelet-rich
um i don't really have any thoughts on
this other than
yeah i didn't even know native americans
asked the jeep company to stop
saying calling the calling it the
cherokee
um which uh
you know i guess not native americans
the cherokee nation would be funny if a
different
if the seminole said it right like hey
wait the
turkeys are absolutely the zoo come on
exactly like your mom's
upset uh well
or should just cut me a little slower
come with some flight jack that's the
thing we think
uh native names are free game
yeah i mean i said it a couple weeks ago
the
the fact that we name it after them
people that we slaughtered but they put
up a hell of a fight
yep so now we we're gonna pay tribute
to you with naming a car after you and
making
so much money off your back yeah if they
need i mean
they could have named it i don't think
they make a dime off of the calling at
the cherokee they
they make it off of the sea they make it
from the actual car
but if they called it will rogers they
will the whoever runs that name is going
to have an issue
you know what i mean so or i have a
great will rogers
scoop okay come on ironically enough 50
year old t
going to it is old man old man
i'll save it because it's i'm it's in me
and kevin
kevin's documentary okay kevin hart's
talking
but it's it's it's [ __ ] hilarious
okay it's like just bad like he got
he he should have been he should have
done been cancelled
yeah i knew i i've heard rumblings
because i remember googling who the [ __ ]
is will rogers when he first moved to
l.a he's everywhere
yeah and just seems like some old white
people [ __ ] there like let's honor this
hilarious okay
okay no it's [ __ ] what he did was
hilarious and his defense
was actually funnier than the first
thing he did that's what i'm gonna say
um now this is a huge story
latino la latinx latinxes
love tom and jerry tom and jerry opened
this weekend
and um and starring colin jost for some
reason
why why is jost in it
i don't he it's not really it's about a
young couple and joe's plays
it's at a hotel and i don't [ __ ] know
it's like
weird muppets yeah the good news is when
joe they filmed in london
and when jost was there i him and jimmy
carr went out
uh for a nice night um now here's the
interesting
le tanks 16 to 18 of the population
and wouldn't you know it they are 35 of
the audience for tom and jerry
nobody understands it someone wrote is
um
artoma jerry uh
cartoon morrissy
if you know what that means oh my god
that's uh
mexicans in l.a i think there's no there
no no even in
mexico love morrissey no one knows why
they they can't even really tell you why
they just
they love morris guy they love him
um and uh so
tom and jerry i mean someone said they'd
like
tom and jerry because it translates i
mean a mouse
it certain cartoons like that just
travel well because
they've been around forever yeah what
was the one
wasn't there a fairy now they look at it
problematic latino mouse
rodrigo what was his name i like ricky
ricardo
go ahead no he's like i'm me mimi
[ __ ] i don't know i don't want to keep
ripping gonzales speed against
yeah yeah yeah sweetie gonzalez uh yeah
not i don't know what he seems to have
bro based on
the there's a character in the
wild bunch uh there was like a
latin guy uh either the wild
i think it's the wild bunch there's like
a if you look at the
the the uh photos there's a
guy who looks like that speedy gonzales
is based on
who's like he's like the local like that
guy like hey
bro i got like the kind of floppy hatted
local
mexican who they had
yeah to like you know for local
knowledge like i know where the water is
oh
agua um so sweetheart
is largely seems based on that guy and
uh did you make that up which one
speaking's always based on this guy no
it's one of those you know when you're
watching
you know when you watch cartoons and
then you see the thing that they based
it on when you
become an adult it's either the wild
bunch or the magnificent seven but
there's one
of them it's based on
and and the yeah and then the mel blanc
did the voices
and of white guy definitely and did
but he also is like the voice over goat
it's not even i mean [ __ ] bugs bun
all the warner brothers and any amazing
timing he's white
yeah my blank um he looks like eric
griffin
he does he looks like uh what's that guy
somebody somebody like white guy johnson
um mr johnson he looks at mr johnson
um so i mean look gregory hines doesn't
look like gregory hines there
the mustache a little bit okay um he
gregory hides me mad
and i think mel blanc would be like i
don't love the black affiliation
um if you want to hear great voices
talking look up mel blank and jack benny
they did a sketch on jack benny's show
and you want to talk about old man t
it is the most satisfying vocal pitches
you've ever you jack yeah
jack benny already had [ __ ] just play
hit a little bit they can't they're not
going to sue us
oh pardon me mister but did
my man come over and put some of my
clothes in your luggage
see
[Music]
so that's that's what it got done that's
speeding up that's the guy just
speeding up yeah now they get a nine
second
applause break whatever you get it
you'll watch it on your own time you
guys have a lot of
you love the videos you love my old man
videos um
so you know good for them
plus they have their is this your king
and it's tom and jerry
are these your kings yes the movie
looked kind of stupid
horat no that's true jerry j
yeah how do you say jerry in uh
geraldo yeah yeah geraldo
geraldo um yes
tomas and geraldo uh dose for
dos por tomas and heraldo and you're
gonna say that at the ticket counter and
you're gonna
dormiendo and uh
now we're r.i.p
we're moving on to uh mr potato head
yo why it's happening
who cares
this is what i don't okay so there's a
stat now they did a the most recent
census
um between five and six percent of
people identify as lgbtq
okay now the the the
startling part of it is
gen z 18 of them identify
uh which is like the joke like
everyone's bi now
um what i don't understand
with a corporation like hasbro is
literally hasbro
makes mr potato head what
i guess i would say what harm did it do
to gender
mr and mrs potato head what harm did it
do to gen
even if the populations it's
you know let's say it's 15 right
of that what i've heard about the lgbtq
stat with gen z is
a lot of a lot of women will
say that they're lesbian even they've
never had a lesbian experience the young
women they just want
affiliation with the brand and i think
they think if i
don't declare it now i won't be able to
go down and check
later on um it's gonna be like a vaccine
passport but for going down on chicks
now okay what i'm saying is
what good what harm was it doing to
gender mr potato head and what good does
it do to ungender it
as an objective like even as like if i'm
how did that
get sold to the board
i don't i mean you know when i think
about it are we misunderstanding it it's
just potato head now right
it's just potato head the way you say it
it's fun
potato head thanks um so
the problem is for me it also is there's
another question that you didn't ask
which is
does it [ __ ] matter if it makes
someone else feel better
i don't play with mr potato head no i
don't i'm not that's what i'm saying
i'm not against yeah keep going i just
mean that okay so obviously
we're not playing with mr potato head
anymore um
so is it what is like when is it just
nostalgia like
ah i don't why change it for our opinion
you know what is what does it do for
anybody
versus i don't know the status quo right
now
like why why have it there i think it's
the same question
if we're just i just maybe i'm coming
from a different place why have mr
potato head if the younger generation
cares about labels and they care about
gender
assignments and they care about labeling
gender-wise
so maybe somebody has a kid and they're
like i just wanted to be
potato head i don't want it to be mr
potato head so i think it's
i don't know is it it's weird
for me a little because i think i don't
feel
i don't think you feel threatened by
it's just one of it seems unnecessary it
seems unnecessary but then
are isn't that what it's
doesn't it just all seem unnecessary to
people that are not the target of the
change
who don't care about it you know yeah
that's like the bathroom argument
until you read one one article about
being trans going to a man's bathroom as
a woman
but right just a [ __ ] nightmare
nightmare so
um i don't i don't know i think it's i
do i really give a [ __ ] no but no i
don't i don't think anyone gives a [ __ ]
i wonder it's an interesting sign of the
times
like is i they were
i think they overestimated how far up
the list they were
in terms of their coming for you who
missed the potato
family they're like people were like
they're coming for us
and it was like what are you talking
about like no they're here
they're right around the corner no dude
you're like maybe 10 years away
so you think they could have not said
anything you don't think there was a
demand yeah i don't think
i i can't imagine there was i don't
think so either
i think that was a just a pr move yeah
to get ahead of something the cops show
up and someone's like i have drugs and
they're like we're here on a burglary
what are you doing ah [ __ ] i thought you
were here for that i feel like that's
what happened to mr potato head where
they
jump the gun on what they thought first
of all what they
what their position is in the country
they're like
you know they're probably waiting on us
at this point
to come with a big decision or
yeah i i don't i guess i just don't
understand
the i guess i don't understand the value
i mean
you're not gonna get rid of gender as a
thing
i don't think you're gonna get rid of mr
i don't think you're gonna get rid of
mrs
i think whether people
like it or not you wouldn't want
me to introduce you as a man
and i wouldn't want you to introduce me
as a woman and maybe that's our own
internalized bigotry and you're a [ __ ]
and you're a
whatever but it's just like feels like
if you don't if you're not i try to do a
joke about it but it's too
complicated if you don't
visually read as a woman
you you're you're probably gonna feel
like you made him you [ __ ] up somehow
you know what i mean like if i don't
read as a man
i mean i know that i read as a lesbian a
certain person um
if i don't read as a man i'll feel like
a
failure like what are you a woman and
even but
it never got to women but women i wish
would have been like what are you a
[ __ ] man
like that because that's even worse than
calling a man a woman
but i wonder what
i just don't think gender is going away
yeah
as i think because i don't i think it's
uh
i don't know if it's helpful it's just
we need organizing
things my issue is not because i have
friends who
especially if in the bay i have a lot of
far left leaning friends that are really
militant about [ __ ]
and sometimes we get in debates and i'm
like well
it's it can be confusing and my friend
just broke
it down and she said well what this was
years ago
and she said well what does it matter
why don't call me whatever i want it
doesn't matter to you it's no sweat off
your back to call me
what my preferred name is or my
preferred pronouns are
and when she put it like that i was like
okay cool yeah that what the [ __ ] do i
care if you're not
you're a she you know i don't care but
i do wonder how
it's confusing to me to get to that
point
like i guess you could just ask what are
your preferred pronouns
but i don't think i'm going to do that
do you know i don't think that's going
to be a
well it's a small it's a small
percent it's a small market it's like
left-handed people
i the world is whether we it's oriented
for right-handed people
it's a little worse for left-handed
people and
i i'm not making an effort yeah to make
it
you know i mean or like
tall p like you know in a lot of
advantages a lot
being tall is an advantage and then i
remember
going to the movies with blake
and a a door that i'd never thought of
he had to do this
okay neil's like tilting his head tilt
his neck
onto his shoulder to fit underneath a
regular door at the mall
okay but those are the things but okay
sorry yeah go ahead no so those are
things he can control right so what do
we do he can't control
sorry he can't control that's right
whereas now we're looking at gender the
kind of the ties are changing to look at
gender as a
choice what do you what do you feel like
it's not
necessarily what you're born at so how
do we
be respectful and mindful of people but
also
i i just know it's not going to be easy
for everyone to ask what are your
preferred pronouns so what do we do how
do we make sure we don't offend
a small part of the population while
also kind of not being
told like you're a [ __ ] you know
what do we it's not unlike the cove
[ __ ] the rollout
for the rule for some of the
the stuff that people want i i'm all for
like if
it's if it's uh
dangerous then that
needs to be changed right anything that
is danger
endangering your life um
if you're
if it's and then there's like a spectrum
of inconvenience
right meaning every form is
miss or mr like these binary things and
then you gotta be like what do i put
um but there's a certain amount of
justice like collateral damage in that
category of like
blake has to [ __ ] tilt his neck he
makes a bunch of money playing
basketball so we probably it's like
small price to pay
but if you don't do you know what i mean
like
yeah no i do but they're not going i'm s
i'm 6
10 we need to change all the doors but
okay you said that you don't think
gender is going away
is it that i mean maybe we've thought
about gender wrong this whole time
or do you think there's just a human
nature aspect there is a i don't think
obviously i think that most people
within a i think within i think most
people
identify or it's binary man or woman i
think like
an overwhelming amount of people
you just i'm a man i'm a woman genitalia
i'm a southern black woman is it
genitalia is a big one and then
you just follow that for the most part
some people are like [ __ ] i don't this
is not
this is not i don't i saw my genitals
and i don't love them
they're not what i thought and think i
should have they are rare
but they are in existence
i guess my question is how much
um reconfiguring does society at large
need to make
to uh to
cater or do the bare minimum for those
people
i and i just don't know it's like the
right hand or the tall or there's
there's a bunch of those things or like
uh remember there was a thing about
seats on airplanes and charging
like overweight people they felt
and it's a bit like yeah i hear i don't
know we're mostly this
size they had to make this seat a
certain size like
for it to work and i don't know i'm sure
someone listening to this could be like
this is what i sound old and callous but
it's it's i really don't know how much
catering
we have to do to every group or maybe
someone listening can write in and say
what they because if someone told me
like i prefer this i'm
great oh i'd never be like no
where i'm from i just like i don't care
i
i don't care it's like it's also not
that major
an issue i don't deal not like i'm
afraid
i just don't i remember me and dave were
on stage one night
and you're not gonna believe us but he
was talking about transgender people
and dave yeah and he goes i saw a
transgender person and i go
where because it's like i never see
transgender people i'm an adult in
hollywood and i almost
never see transgender people again not
saying they don't exist
i'm not saying that i guess it's just a
small uh amount a population
number how much
uh accommodation do they require and i
now having said that i bet there was
pushback on
ramps for people in wheelchairs of
course
like i'm sure i mean i've heard people
complain about having to build ramps
they don't stop they don't stop doing it
but i don't know what the stats are on
people with disabilities
um yeah well it would also i also feel
like a lot of the conversation
is taking place on behalf of people
who who are like gender neutral or
whatever and
i don't always hear i hear like this is
inconvenient or
why is this happening even me like why
are we changing mr potato hood who cares
if you care fine but whatever
but i suspect the
the fuss people make is never as big as
what the
actual person wants or what they're
actually requesting you know how
sometimes people make a bigger deal
on behalf of black people or on behalf
of others and it's like
we who said that yeah like well it
becomes a game of telephone and it
becomes a
and it becomes a game of telephone at
times it also becomes a game of
the cultural flopping thing
and it becomes a thing where i the
flopping it's like when you're i tell
somebody it's like when you're sick in
bed and your mom's giving you sympathy
and you get like
extra sick
people act like that to me babies when
they're sick
i can't like does not confuse me that's
funny
i think it's fun to be a baby in bed i
know you're going to worry about
yourself
it's fun to make i like
making funny noises in bed meaning
like when i get up i'll go like no
no neil it's a funny thing to do when
you get out of bed
to do like a baby girl fawn
voice sorry guys i'm where i'm from
in comedy it's funny to make noises
coming out of you that people wouldn't
expect but i'm
i'm old-fashioned i'm uh i'm an old-man
phrase
i mean this is a whole other this is can
you please have any issues
well that's the thing this is lady gaga
that's the i said to somebody um
somebody called me about literally just
to talk about fame
okay and i somebody who's like newly
famous
and they were like you didn't tell me
it's [ __ ] and i was like
this is the thing that people don't
expect about fame
lady gaga sings so good they shot her
dog walker that's how good a singer she
is
so good they took her dogs and shot her
dog walker
it's so cr it makes everyone so crazy
these these talents that
you can you can they get so crazy that
they want to kill you
you need security and then on the flip
side
they want to kill you they want to they
want to kill every celeb i mean they
want to kill
the only death threats eminem gets you
know how many death threats gaga gets
gaga you know how much she gets
um she gets so many to death threats
like there's a probably 30 40 50
celebrities who get so many death
threats
you can't it's just it's like
i know uh someone who gets so many death
threats he said stop
telling me stop telling me because it
doesn't it
i don't it doesn't make they're either
gonna do it or they're not
the threat is most deaf didn't joke on
bill maher like 15 12 years ago where he
was like
talking about bin laden where he's like
who keeps making videos like calling
like
you know i'm coming for you that's what
death threats are basically like right
they just want to
they want to it's like a pump fake you
now you say it's the dick pic for
celebrities but it is
which is not incorrect it is and it's
it's just i feel like it comes with the
territory
because like you're saying it makes
people insane
yeah yeah you did a thing that everybody
knows about and i'm this close to you
yes or i can maybe get this close to a
thing that's an impactful
thing but the funny thing is she's to
your point she's so famous that
they shot her dog walker and she said
please return the dogs
no questions asked
ask questions nope that's between you
and my dog walker
it's got nothing to do with me dog i
couldn't believe i'm like
no questions asked that's really [ __ ]
up yeah that's incredibly fun
and also if you work for celebrity
that's how much you mean to them
it's dude that's what i've heard a
really funny story like that
where somebody was had like their right
hand
man like let's call him uh craig
right the guy big celebrity had a
right-hand man like craig
craig craig just hey craig's here me and
craig craig craig craig
and one day a friend of mine saw the
celeb they were doing a movie together
and
my friend saw the celebrity goes uh hey
where's craig and he goes uh
yeah he's like in the hospital and he
goes how come he goes
i don't know oh wow
these are heroes ladies and gentlemen
these are your heroes
now uh yeah that's uh it's a
it's it's a nightmare for the dog walker
but that's okay you know what's funny is
that is indica
indicative of
which we'll get to woody allen in a bit
what you can get away with it's like a
double-edged sword where you people want
to kill you and you could technically
kill people
yeah you could
basically got five people killed at the
capitol like more than three
two five whatever he shot people on
fifth avenue
he did shoot but the apprentice was that
good it was so [ __ ] good
the apprentice was that was good enough
that he can get away with it but that is
that's where you go like boy is that
what's worth
that what's worth getting your dog
stolen and your dog
your employees shot yeah like it's
brazil
in [ __ ] 1975 like
it's mexico city yeah it's insane
yeah it's insane like you can't even
she hasn't even come out with a hit
lately i mean guys it's that the
the the the movie the shallow lalo movie
hasn't been up for two years
two three years
the joke i did about that that i
couldn't ever do in public was uh
uh i saw the movie i it was a little
[ __ ]
um now so
i yeah it's terrifying and
it also speaks to the holes people have
inside themselves
that they go i want that kind of knowing
that it could get their dog stolen
yeah and their friend shot yeah but i
want it
you sure no it'll be different when i'm
there okay
then okay you might turn into craig okay
okay no value for human life where's
craig where's gray
so that's pretty great now stevie wonder
he's got the right idea
what happened he's claims he's moving to
ghana
well you know they have the thing right
they have the repatriation for
for african-americans but he claims he's
moving to ghana
and his reasoning is he
wants to protect his grandkids from
living in a country that does not
value them uh to which i say what about
your kids
could have moved a little earlier by my
calculations you started having money in
75.
um yeah so he's moving
and who this is what marcus garvey
wanted
uh yeah go back to africa i believe
marcus garvey
um uh wanted his plan was
let's all go back to average yeah yeah
you know who else had this plan that
people underestimate
lincoln not not a joke yeah you know
also the plan
or who argued uh tom jefferson
yeah so well no he didn't want them all
going back
sally you stay back sally i
sally i wanted to go over something with
you in my study
wow and then chamber music place like a
mozart because it's you know the 1700s
so it's not
porn music it's it's a sexy mo
mozart um
so i if you can do it
do it like you know i know what i've
been talking to people that are
a lot more people that i knew were not
in la for the last
six months yeah like
kevin nealon has been in nashville for
three months he said
kevin neal pivoted from going to ghana
to save
your children to kevin like
i think hey i mean hannibal's never
really in america but he's been all over
um like people are
there's also a lot of people in hawaii a
lot of people like
there's the the austin and the and the
nashville people but there's
there's a home uh you're like there's
more
than meetings what's happening i wish
i'd gone somewhere honestly it's a
stupid podcast
hadn't held me back um because uh
yeah but would you move to africa oh
no because it's far as [ __ ] but would i
have like
if i could have some sort of vacation
home there absolutely
your of the mind calculation for racism
in america
is worth the first world benefits
it's not so much that it's that i'm
i think you're saying that racism's
worth it no no no
i think it's i i guess i'm not and i'm
not saying that
um stevie wonder is but i'm not naive
enough to think
i'm gonna move somewhere that i don't
know much about the local culture
and the traditions and everything and be
like and no more problems i'm not saying
maybe it won't be racism but i
i don't know i've lived in a lot of
countries so i would need to do more
i'd want to visit i'd want to see you
know what i mean like i'd wanna
is there i guess it's probably a feeling
but is there a thing in america that
would happen that you would go like
that'll do it that'll do it for banks in
the states
i think what is more interesting
is to there's so much land in this
country that is
unused that is for sale that is cheap
and i wish there was a way to organize
um just like
i believe there's value in leaving and
going to gun especially because
there's an offer there and but
i do think there's value here like we
can beat white people at their own game
there is there's so much benefits for
living in this country
that yeah of course mostly white people
take advantage of but
a lot of people don't take advantage of
it because they don't know about it they
don't know about certain
land opportunities certain things i mean
if you look at that well that's what
stacey abrams did
yeah i mean it was not she just
was like you know we're allowed to vote
and there were all these impediments and
she would just change the
get the laws changed a little bit but
there's there's so much i mean even if
you look at
blm i'm not talking about black lives
matter i'm talking about
uh barry larry myers no
go just google a [ __ ] blm map you
know go look up
where there's public open land and what
you can do with it and what you aren't
allowed to do with it and
guess what why people take advantage of
it a hunt most of
my people take advantage of most white
people love a coupon and a groupon
but they're taking advantage of
something that's taking advantage of
i'm not saying taking advantage little
fine print
fine print but there's loopholes there
are uh
bureau land management there's there are
so many loopholes oh i didn't i
literally thought you meant blm no
blm bureau land management so um there's
free open land that we pay for for
with our tax dollars that is not i'd
like to think a lot of people
wanted to join black lives matter and
then was like oh this is about land all
right [ __ ] it
and now i have a farm think of it think
of all the white people who are like
be alive no i was marching for rocks
so if you there's so much information
that
i i believe in that is great that ghana
has offered something but
if you don't just take a look at the
fine print in the loopholes and things
that
white people take advantage of you can
do so much on blm land you're allowed to
be there
ghana basically if you don't know they
basically have
they it's a it's almost like what
america did
for white people after it's a gi bill
yeah yeah
yeah i don't know what you get low taxes
and property yeah
it's just incentive to move there and
you can become a citizen
and they make it easier they just give
you like a handout to like
you know start a life there but as much
i think that's great
i think there the issue here is not oh
my god
racism or ghana it's where there's so
much
there's so much information out there
that isn't getting into the hands and
guess what
everybody is allowed to use all this
like let's just take
the blm for example like everyone's
allowed to be like you can literally
claim
20 acres of that land if it like there's
things that people don't know and i feel
like if you really mobilized
and and utilize the information that's
out there
stacey abrams would get off her ass i
know
come on stacy do more do stuff um so
i guess that's what i think um all right
stevie wonder
rest in in
power okay
um a director said you shouldn't cast
straight people as gay people
castrate what do you mean you shouldn't
cast straight people
in gay parts ever trying to unhear
castrate
i know you are we all are um oh wait oh
okay
a movie director said like you shouldn't
ever cast a straight person i feel like
we're past
it just cast a gay person but a lot of
people don't want to identify as gay so
that's another one and like actors don't
want to identify
as gay because it's not gonna it doesn't
help no
it does it it helps like in the moment
like broadway
a week of press and yeah you go on like
good morning america
yeah and it's yeah now you're the gay
guy yeah
but you're right that they don't
i remember arsenio got in trouble
there's a video of our cinema like
screaming at the end people in the
audience started heckling when he went
into the audience
screamed at him and but they're like you
don't have a it was
act up and they were like you don't have
enough gay guests and he's like i don't
have enough guests that you know
are gay is the issue yeah um
so i that's the
it's also i don't know i mean uh
i guess it's a bit like where
part of its uh act is who's best for the
part
right just like who's the best person
who do i like seed
doing this i'm
if i if i play a
comedy writer i might or a comedian
and it's me or it's just what do i like
seeing in this part i don't know who do
you like the best
as the director um wait what are you
saying
you should be able to cast whoever
you think is the best person right but
there's biases and there's racism
straight you say get lost for the week
and go do some gay [ __ ] and
you you the part is yours open a grinder
account
meet up with three guys see what happens
and uh if you're
now now you're now you're curious um
i have a couple unpopular opinions
there we go
of um um the blues
is the music genre the blues
i i enjoy the blues
but i do not enjoy the blues
uh more than others here's my here's my
issue with the blues
the blues is a chord
progression right a melody or chord
progression
played in a self-congratulatory way
so um if if the
if the chord progression is
[Music]
right that's like how it's written and
you go marino now now
wow now everyone goes like whoa
you just took longer that's all you did
but people are so like whoa
did you see and it's i i will also argue
that it's white people
fetishizing black people because it's
almost always white people going
do you see what that guy did and there
we won't get into
blues brothers movie um
it's performative and
self-congratulatory and
i wanted to call them out
so a genre started when slave masters
take away
slaves drums and to get through the uh
oppression and the the pain of being
asleep they just started blues
and neil thinks it's too
self-congratulatory
annoying blues pick a new [ __ ]
person i'm not going to come off let me
come off blues
as like [ __ ] blind willie johnson and
[ __ ] all those like the i understand how
it started i understand
it's just it's basically just guitar
right maybe i'll chicago blues
okay let's get started i'll go with
chicago blues
self-congratulatory and performative
okay
sorry chicago blues okay you got called
out
okay play the song well
there we go
here's the here's the good news
i'm less popular forever what i just
said you're more proud so in some ways
i brought attention to the blues and
made white people root for it
more and isn't that what you want
um i have a uh
bank's gonna unapologize on an apology
so last episode i said
that the bachelorette
who wants to date the black bachelor the
first black bachelor who did blackface i
round it up to blackface
that apology still stands because i said
she actually just went she attended a
party the apology still stands
so well can you get a sound effect of a
referee saying the
play uh the
play call on the field stance yeah
please thank you
um so
she did she didn't do blackface then i
did a little deep diving
and it's worse than if she did a one
idiot
blackface super blackface if she did one
idiotic black face it's bad but
it's a whole this lady is not a fan of
black people
and now this is just my opinion i don't
know if this is true with my grandmother
my grandmother's dead but i will say was
she
she uh the quote that i remember was
she moved she was born in ireland moved
to america lived in chicago
and then moved back to ireland when they
moved in
never found out who they was but i have
my suspicions
i got a few i got a short list what was
her maiden name
uh again give that
and give up my most of my
passwords you're out of your mind okay
you're out of your goddamn might have
just done that um so
come to find out maga hats
fine whatever you're allowed to be a
mega lover okay
uh she there's not backface brown face
she dressed up
basically as speedy gonzales a few
parties
okay okay not so bad then
all these accounts came out of people
when she was on the show being like
oh that girl i went to high school with
her i went to college with her
she made fun of me for liking black men
she bullied me for having black friends
she didn't like any of the black girls
she would talk [ __ ] about black people
all these accounts came out now they
could all be far
like false and hearsay so i'm not saying
it's a truth
i'm just saying i don't know
i don't know if she gets a full apology
but it seems worse what i'm finding out
is actual
belief against i don't get
them it would be hard-pressed you'd be
hard-pressed to
go to a plantation
party at a plantation yeah
and not be cree
i was creeped out by going to the museum
of slavery
do you know what i mean like right and i
said something because it's
so overwhelming at the slave museum yeah
that was the first thing the
african-american museum
it's but it's the first three floors of
slavery
um they get you with slavery they and
they they
you come for the slavery state for the
motown um
that's their slogan um
so right so to go
i was telling somebody the other day i
have a hard time being friends with
people
and i could never listen to like mumford
and sons because of the banjo it just
felt wrong
like once lady antebellum yeah i was
like no
i can't i can't do both
you can't do both you can't listen to
to mandolin right that
kind of you can't do it so
the fact that yeah i don't doubt that
she's racist
yeah so to me if a simple idiotic black
face and being ignorant i'm not saying
that's great but
uh the the the things i saw when i deep
dived
i was like i don't think this lady likes
black people that much maybe some lady
that
went to a plantation party you'll never
believe
you're not going to sit down um
yeah i don't i don't i don't doubt it so
there we go
all right that's hard-hitting journalism
racism um
okay we got a big dock watch
pele on netflix fine
did you watch it no i didn't watch pele
pele i mean i was going to go on a plane
i was going to go to payload peel i've
seen peel
uh it's it was fine he didn't he was as
great as soccer
that nothing much not like the matter
nothing much
i still want to watch america oh it's
good it's exciting you can't believe
it's it's a movie it's correct you
cannot believe
how mr plot mister it's the most
cinematic
correct you cannot believe circular
callbacks
just like call backs oh like the the
the uh the final conflict and
how he chooses to go with okay
just go ahead is it team or family
that part he goes you know he
work he's in italy he's with the most
undesirable
losing team he takes him to winning but
in the world cup
he has to play for argentina in italy
against
uh it's like that's what the stuff was
it was a
it was a lot not like i don't care about
the world cup
this one doesn't con maradona is not so
much about
the world cup it's a lot more about him
yeah no of course
yeah that just reminded me of what i
didn't like about pele
which is it it's not
it's like is he gonna play in the 1970
world cup
is it like at 30 for 30 more just kind
of
what happened with heart yeah or is it
yeah and they do the thing where all the
old players get together and tell their
funny stories and
um yeah it just was not great but you
know i'll take what i can get okay
now this is a bigger one
um now i watch this allen vs pharaoh
documentary bianca and i gotta say
it's probably my least favorite woody
allen movie
that i've that i've watched that's the
joke by the way that i did the other
night that killed
um i think i mentioned it early in
pakistan anyhow
um do i get a do you apologize
i don't think i'm gonna apologize
okay but but
you get what i was saying after part two
the here's the here's my problem he
within 98
did some sheisty [ __ ] with dylan
right yeah the hbo
thing isn't journalism and i don't
i think i'm looking for journalism i'm
looking for absolute like the stuff i
was reading last
week about moses moses pharaoh like this
happened did you know this did you know
this did you know that somebody
sent me another link to it um what uh
to more like holes in the
so i i don't know if i engaged in what
about
ism what the kids call what about ism
i think he it seems like he did some to
dylan from what i can tell
from what i it seems really pretty clear
that he did something to dylan
um and that he's gross
not sue ye no no he married i mean yeah
of course
no he talks about they have an excerpt
from his book last night
in the version and he talks about
him and suny's first kiss
as if it's cool yeah
and you're just like dog
not only read the room read the earth
we don't [ __ ] play that [ __ ] like you
can't be he goes if i do say so myself
pretty smooth and you're just like
really hello hbo cancel me
like whoa just gross [ __ ] yeah
and um
so he's out of his mind and
they here's a dirty trick they did
screenwriter i'm sorry he gave all of
his papers to princeton
woody allen did um not his photos though
cause he's not stupid
um he gave all his papers to princeton
and
for the cinema studies program and the
guy goes
you know i've read all the scripts and
it's just young woman after young woman
after young woman and then they do a
montage of him
the manhattan movie
with mariel hemingway i never understood
why
people were cool like i was like she
said is that illegal
right the whole time you're like is this
a movie about a sting operation
is this like a he gets arrested right at
the end of this
no it's just a summer love
um but they did a thing where they do a
montage of him
kissing younger women but at one point
it's like julia
julia lewis juliette lewis who's [ __ ]
great actor
he makes up with her he's 50
he's 60 she's 26
24. just kind of creepy just creepy but
and but it's but then you go but it's in
the in the um
context of hollywood that's the game
it's like you look at
you ever see those things like tom
cruise's girlfriend and
top gun and then his top crew it's
they're the same age
yeah and in the new top gun still he's
not going to be with old keller mcgillis
right um but uh so there
it just felt there it's like some cheap
shots
or some because the guy's written 100
and some screenplays
yeah like he's got i wanna be with a
younger woman he's like
you know he probably he literally goes
he's probably going like
and like imagining the screenwriting
in the movie it's like this is [ __ ]
unnecessary if you have a good case
stop doing this [ __ ] but i'm expecting
journalism
in an emotion fight um
so boing boing boing i give it two boys
uh i don't mean boner i mean like
yeah it's it's [ __ ] gross
and even if you know
whatever me is guilty of
i don't it's like with the with the
bulls documentary
i remember before the bulls documentary
came out a friend of mine was like
who's in journalism it's like yeah but
he approved it right so it's not
really journalism and
like yeah but if he doesn't approve it
you don't you don't have any footage
right he michael jordan owned that
footage basically we've co-owned it
so i'm looking for like but what about
me as [ __ ] right
leave that for the blogs but you didn't
have
that with the michael jackson
documentary no
but you are very like you
are a proponent of that documentary you
didn't say like i don't know of
any known holes in the michael jackson
documentary
do you know what i mean like there was
from the from early on
or from two years ago when moses farrow
wrote that blog
you go ah this seems credible
there i there's no version of that for
michael jackson
i also don't think he did it we'll be
right back after this
um no i but um
yeah like that's the difference to me is
i don't
have a thing
it's almost like my thing with what
would mia faro is like
it's kind of a rel it's not irrelevant
she it's a character witness thing
yeah like is this the best character
witness
but you know what about dylan
dylan i think is a better character
witness
based on no information she hasn't done
anything
like that that's what i'm saying so why
she hasn't done anything
like if you read the moses pharaoh thing
where you're like
ugh
and the other thing about mia ferro she
reminds me
of women from my mom's church
who were pious yet
underneath the piety was [ __ ] rage
and whenever someone's too pious i'm
like
yeah for sure something's going on there
like there's not a full story going on
um
so it's like the great ian edwards one
time we were watching a comedian
kill and ian goes yeah but what's the
secret
that's how i feel with me about it's
like uh you're
you're raging and it's it's pre-existing
and i can't but i'm a dick i'm a dick
for saying it obviously but that's what
people
that's what people that's why we fill
stadiums is because i'm
we don't feel safe i mean whatever uh
but
do you know what i mean yeah like i see
that
but i and i think woody allen's a
garbage person yeah exactly so
um i have a non-doc watch
scripted watch um it
is one of the best shows i've ever seen
in my entire life
like up there with the wire up there
with
i can't believe how good the show is and
i didn't know existed
here's the deal it's israeli that's
probably why i didn't
know about it it's called tough pill
it's called our boys you cannot believe
how good this [ __ ] show is
what's it about so basically these three
so then the cool thing about it is it
happens
it takes you in real time throughout the
situation but it uses it's a real story
the whole thing is 100 real but they
dramatize it
and you go through how everything played
out so there's these three kids that got
kidnapped by arabs these three israelis
they got kidnapped by arabs
and like i think in jerusalem and then
as
uh and what were arabs doing in
jerusalem go ahead
how they led arabs and keep talking okay
so
uh they uh so that kind of united the
country
almost like a george floyd situation so
it really united the country
very much it just like it because they
were really young kids
this is based on a true story right this
happened yeah because i've read i've
either read a review of our boys
or story yeah so this happened in 2014
or 15.
and so then um okay i won't tell you who
but you'll find out
soon into it someone goes and
and tries to kidnap an airboy as revenge
and you see the their version of like
their cia go through like you see from
the
beginnings of it and you see exactly
what happens
and so it turns into like obviously arab
israeli politics but like
there's like vibes of like making a
murderer in there because they're using
they're
dramatizing it okay no no it's
it's scripted but it's based on
everything so you see the um
when they finally recover uh
surveillance
footage it's the real surveillance
footage and then the actors are
obviously trying to act similar to like
exactly what happened but
the way it goes down because they're you
go into the far
right extreme orthodox
um i didn't know so much about israeli
extremists you know
you really only hear about arab
extremists and you go into
you go into this investigation so it's
not
it's not mossad no okay it's not
like israeli intelligence no it's it's
it's shabbat the shabak
which is their fbi okay and they have a
section that
um they go after israeli extremists so
it's like the jewish division oh okay
so they kind of surveil israeli white
supremacists
israeli white supremacists and then it's
like it's the investigation
see things in a white con okay so
israeli white supremacist there's wires
there's
sting operations to try to catch it and
because
the balance of peace is hanging in the
balance
the sorry the hanging balance is like
okay the arabs are now pissed and so
everything they do has to be
very careful it is it's so
good right there you have to watch i
know you don't watch scripted [ __ ]
do you watch subtitles yeah it doesn't
i'm not all the if it's if it's if
there's an
ending there's a per it's perfect okay
great if how many episodes
uh four or six okay i would have
preferred four seconds
tell me which four or six to watch no
it's so you don't want it to
i'll watch it i'll absolutely it's just
it's nice that you see the arab side of
things the israeli side of things the
shabbat side of things
and the infighting and i don't know if
you it's not boring
it's like it feels like you're watching
if you've ever watched a netflix doc
about murder that's dragged you in
or something where you're just like [ __ ]
i have to go to sleep it's 4am yeah all
right what's it on
it is on hbo great it's been
our boys hello hbo turn it back on
i made a mistake about the woody allen
cancel me um
emails everybody
[Music]
hi neil and bianca um i was watching
an aoc video earlier today um and
as a latina millennial myself i'm a huge
fan
but i'm wondering if one of the places
democrats are getting
getting it wrong is by constantly
talking about the working class
working class working class and poverty
um i think a lot of working class
people like want to be diluted into
believing that
they can be super super rich and
wealthy and you know the american dream
which is a lie that the republicans are
still selling them
and it just looks sexier um
you know even though the democrats are
telling the truth about the working
class
i just feel like no one wants to be
reminded that they're poor
so let me know what you think thanks
she's got a good point she's got a good
voice
i found it a little sad
um she's got uh
she's got a good point i don't know what
how you rebrand it you're she's not
wrong
there's a quote that's attributed to
five different people but
that i'm sure i've said on here before
which is
alexis de tocqueville did a book about
america
and he said america doesn't have any
poor people it just has temporarily
embarrassed rich people
that's really which is like and he said
in like 1810
that stuck um but
uh yeah working but no i literally was
trying to think of a new one i was like
working class no that's what we're
trying to get away from
right uh uh backbone
[ __ ] yeah like there's not
what do you what are we
upwardly mobile could be good you know
the the
one thing that the republicans and
conservatives do good there's a few
guys i forgot their exact name but they
can be they it's not david uh david from
it's uh the guy with the toupee
yeah they are they they they coin
perfect terms yeah
okay they like they'll just put they are
so good at labeling so good
at democratic messages uh messaging
putting an albatross around democratic
issues with a horrible title it's just
like
you're like i i don't want it
and i'm i sent the i started the bill
right and i'm like that we need somebody
who's right
once yes that's that's exactly what i
was thinking about uh we need someone
who can encode
a message in a way that is disarming to
people
yeah and but
you know upwardly mobile workers
how about that that's too long and
jumbly you're a [ __ ] uh
it's nice to be like snazzy yeah i mean
yeah you're not wrong
and mobile i mean i'm trying to put some
because everything mobile sounds like
you're an influencer but all the
democratic ones
are so pc boring you know do you mean
like build back better
don't you dare talk about billboard bill
bill bob
bilbach billbock bachmann billboard
um yeah you're not wrong uh i would go
upward ascendant the rising class
i think that's pretty good phoenix yeah
but just like the rising phoenix
university
um yeah rising class
huh they just mean poor people i mean i
don't think that when they call them
working class
they used to say blue collar so working
class seems more inclusive
you're right and we don't have we don't
know
so that's pretty great goodbye um
if you got one let us know well you've
got man play some [ __ ]
come on banks no discussion
no [ __ ] analysis paralysis by neil
i'm gonna ask you a question and i want
your answer
what do you think the percentage is
okay of white folks
who listen to name it
hip hop whatever black music so they can
hear the n word and feel cool with it
chappelle show is
right up there with it man it's you were
the kid in the car weren't you
like hey you called us inwards man we're
[ __ ] awesome
i dude it's just a random thought that
came to me tonight uh
he is white knuckling this um it's not a
bad question
um no i don't i
it's like the that morgan wallen kid
the country star nobody's that great
they're not going to listen to a hip-hop
song
that has it if it's a bad song i think
the first priority is
entertainment and then this if it's got
an n word in it
it makes it like a little more dangerous
to white people you know to white young
people that are like
um like that that
that by the way big j okerson comedian
yeah gave him the part in that sketch
but he didn't have money for sag
no you could have spotted it 400 bucks
or something
i didn't know that's what happened if he
would have asked like came in
yeah but i just didn't know that's fast
um
i didn't have money when we shot it
either it was like i wasn't like yeah
but it was i yeah i could have something
it was he couldn't get a loan it was one
of the things like
you'll get the money back the funny
thing is i the kid who
wasn't it probably still gets one from
it yeah they
really still any time yeah um
so the so i think it helps but i don't
think it's the
or help i don't there's plenty of songs
that have the n-word in it that white
people have no interest in
but if it's no well let's change it to
how many
why what percentage of white people just
like
to be like close to [ __ ]
being called [ __ ] or just that type of
music and
how much like you know well they took
the fun out of it i'll say that
um 20 years ago it was really something
now it's like now it's you just feel bad
the whole time
um the
i think people want to get closer to a
culture that seems new and exciting and
dangerous
yeah even santino has a joke where he's
like
uh almost called else almost said it to
me you know like garf yeah you know
how like oh that's that black enjoying
being called it
that's immutable like that'll never
change
that and i've made the argument before
which is
it means they are you're included
basically um and that's exciting
when you're when you want to be included
so
but i don't think that there i don't
think it's a malicious
reason i don't think you're like this i
got the new one boys and it's like
garbage
dude i was at the gym one time
there was a white red-headed guy
[Music]
and on his hair makes him seem whiter go
ahead he was very white yeah
and on his forearm was a tattoo that
said
white [ __ ] it's a tough one
and i walked up to him and i said can i
take a photo of that
and he let me when i still have it did
you pose with it or just
no it it was already a lot going on
pointing
the whoopsie daisy the wubsy daisy arms
i i asked them like what i just have to
white [ __ ] it was huge yeah he was like
i grew up there a lot of black people
and i thought it was fine at the time
and yeah
they led him astray he was led astray
that's
yeah that feels like a they
punked him kind of like you know what
you should get
[ __ ] it i'll pay for it i was like you
know one person said
you're like tattooed to not be raped
in prison not the best tattoo i've ever
heard
don't get a that tattoo okay uh will
move move on goodbye you've got
mail neil and banks long time listener
love the cast
man and then he put in parentheses cali
style
i like him funny and something that
people
haven't probably said for 25 years you
know like cali style
whenever someone says cali it's an
indicator
that he and i are not going to be
friends hey kelly
yeah like catty and if you roll the l
it's over cali kelly
kelly yeah um anyway you guys had an
episode called homie hoppers and now i
want to talk about relationship hoppers
currently dating a girl who seems to
always be in a new relationship
and it's made me question the organic
connection of ours
yes she recently moved here to
california and had a bf lined up that
she met
online wow uh we met about nine months
after she moved and she told me she's
never had a connection like ours and
we're soul mates
upon further inspection let's call it a
conversation
i found out the dude she started seeing
when she got here was staying with her
within two weeks
watching her dogs and going to work
events with her apparently the guy
got shot because the ladies gaga
um the lady is a guy keep in mind she
gave me a key
after two weeks she said they were never
serious uh knowing more about her past
through just combo though i noticed all
relationships last around two three
months
uh with a few exceptions she's been with
more than a handful of partners but
she's never had great sex until us
uh recently we were talking about a
vacation and she immediately said no
doesn't want to bump into an x there
making me believe she might have
feelings for him still
also is the x going to be on every
vacation
um she also said she never uh whatever
guys i'm wondering if i have a chronic
can't be alone situation here aka
relationship hopper uh what's known
i think in two kind of terms uh serial
monogamist
yes um but my nightmare yeah this woman
is uh
a bad news no is it you can't
i don't know w i have friends like this
so i don't want to but like move
boyfriend i just find it
i think everyone's a little motivated
it's like guys get girlfriends for sex
and stuff like that but
this is we get to the point where it's
weird yeah
there's no dishonest and contradictory
like
right exactly no i just um i don't
i know women do like being in
relationships and that security and
stuff but
she's lining up dudes like you
you know if that guy worked out would
she be you know what i mean it's just i
don't
trust it and if he feels this way it's
for a reason
it's not because he's being insecure i
think there's where there's smoke
there's fire i don't trust her
unfortunately do you trust me no i don't
i'd be gone
you what do you mean what are you going
to say i think say i'm going on vacation
to that place i know she's not coming
i'll tell you what anything you want to
tell your fake boy like i don't even
know what the [ __ ] she's talking about
once you catch somebody in enough
contradictions it's kind of over
right it's like who are you you're
[ __ ] either a liar or dumb
right so what which do you want me to
put on cause of death on your
on your toe tag should i put liar or
dumb
um he also closed the letter by saying
take it sleazy i'm out goodbye
i like it take it sleazy and i'm out as
well you know what this reminds me of
that have you seen that episode of rick
and morty where there's like a dating
app
and they keep uh they keep finding
their love mate immediately like it's
like
neil it's always been you and then will
comes in it's like no it's will
it's like it's like i think sometimes
she some people are like
it's they buy the story and they want to
believe that they're so
like i'm just blessed and i love love
yeah and it's like yo no this is
different than the last one this is
the immediate anytime it's immediate too
soon especially with a guy if a guy's
like
way too into it way too soon like men
aren't like
built like this tote tag time
you've got mail during the texas segment
in your last episode i uselessly
observed that new york is pretty much
the texas of democratic cities
we act like it's so great and ignored
that we live in walk-in closets for the
sake of bagels public transportation
which is really a homeless shelter on
wheels at this point i don't know why
why you're bringing them into it but
don't worry bill de blasio is organizing
flash mobs to dance in the street and
bring back the culture
uh i don't i know what he means
texas thing is that they act like
they're not
dependent on america they're not part of
america and that they're not dependent
on
funding from the central government
right new york
is gross new york is
very gross it's a real point it's a good
it's an
interesting point in life where you go
this place is gross where it's
everything's filthy
everything you cannot there's they don't
have a power washer
powerful enough to wash new york it's
it's the grime it's a hundred years
it's it's uh it's the it's the vincent
price
thriller it's the funk of 40 000 years
it really is like wow
and you can't get light there's too many
big buildings you cannot see light
like the average you wake up in
california and you're like
this is nice sunshine at
9 30. you wake up in new york and you're
like did i sleep until
5 15. and then you and i and it's 11.
you cannot get access like there's
an hour yeah um so
you don't miss it i mean i miss the
stimulation that's what you get in new
york is
you get a lot of reps um you get to
judge
thousands of people a day it's good i
mean walking here versus walking in new
york
you bump into like eight people and
10 dogs goodbye um you've got hello
bianca anyway back to the topic
uh neil it's been a while since you talk
about the fats
it's a subject i'm curious about in
regards to one you're concerned with
mother aya and two
the new one-man show you're working on
regarding self-acceptance my question is
has your viewpoint on chubby's changed
chubby che i'm a chubby chicken tummy
t-shirt um today i
somehow landed on a podcast interview
with sonia renee taylor
who where she was talking about the new
book the body is not an apology
apology uh you can kind of guess what
the basics of the books
might be based uh but i was uh really
intrigued by one particular insight she
gives
the breakdown essentially is that any
kind of judgment on the human body
is in direct support of the systems
meant to
maintain power uh by
the white patriarchal capital is control
meaning body shaming or disgust for any
human being
is a wrong on the ladder of the same
system that is supported by racism
yeah she actually had a long-ass letter
paragraph and i cut it
and it was still long lady i tried to
help you you can't be helped
what's the skimmit anyways what'd you
think uh neil you often say
shame works but i think i disagree it
encourages self-hate not healing that's
not very i a potential obnoxious
catchphrase
um she's funny from the people who
brought you that's so raven
uh that's not soya
i don't uh i
the fats are tough for me they are
the fats are tough for me because
i see it as a simple
uh gluttony issue
it's like the catholic in me sees
gluttony why why at one point though
because it isn't
if there i believe that there is a
there's a small percentage of people
who eat the appropriate amount of
calories per day
and gain weight i just don't think it's
a big percentage
what i mean is so when you say oh
sometimes i feel like gluttonous and
like fat
people or very overweight people have a
mental
issue but you're not talking about
someone who's out of shape you're
talking about
someone that's like morbidly obese right
somebody uh
like out of shape like the proper bmi
i mean not tight like a little
gut a little like floppy arm a little
yeah i mean what what do i think of that
no no no no no no i'm saying that when
you say
you think someone has mental health
issues like untreated mental health
issues it's the
like just constantly ballooning and
gaining weight i don't think you're
talking about everything yeah
yeah yeah like that yeah anybody if
you're like within the bmi
if your doctor doesn't say anything
right so but there's a lot of people who
are just that and maybe you're
and you're not attracted to that
obviously you're not attracted to
someone who's morally obese most people
aren't
unfortunately for them but let's just
talk about
not i don't i would take it out of
attraction even because that's not
attraction i'm just saying for you
your issue right yeah is like
you've said you know you like fit bodies
you think that's the best
thing me and the entire medical
profession like i'm not saying you only
i'm just talking i'm trying to get to a
point
so if if someone's just out of shape
right like yeah do you think they
deserve as much shame or judgment
as someone who is morbidly obese because
i don't think we make a
we don't really make a distinction
between you we just say fat
yeah i me i guess morbidly obese
um the word morbid makes me seem like a
real jerk but
uh
yeah uh the i just
i don't think i think it's
uh like debt or smoking or drug
addiction
or any of the things that
are easier easier to avoid
uh when you're
maybe it's easier when you're white
right it might just be easier to
um avoid all those pitfalls
but it's still not easy
right i want to eat sugar
all the time for it [ __ ] every
literally every meal
i can't i can't because it's gr it's
just not healthy
um and so
that's my thing is is is
expecting sympathy as bird did that joke
about
he's like i'm sick of seeing fat people
crying on tv oh my god
and that was set up and but it was about
how on the biggest loser all these
people crying he's like
you're not for some reason you're
leaving out the amazing
feats of eating that you did like he and
then he goes i had a roommate
who used to buy ben and jerry's let it
melt
and then drink it that's so
nice like again is that
what i'm how much sympathy do i have to
have for that person
who's doing this thing that's completely
abnormal
and completely beyond the pale
that's what and i don't think that's the
average fat person
is drinking ben and jerry's but burr's
point is like you have these incredibly
wild rock and roll nights of eating
you gotta you know eventually it'll get
you
you know rick james [ __ ] died fairly
young
from being someone said from an acute
case of rick james
like you you will there is a price to
pay for this stuff
and i at the same time i know rehab for
drugs
rehabilitation works better than
punishment
i also think shame works it's gotten
smokers it's reduced smoking massively
and even the tobacco companies you think
about like what
the oil companies are doing now with
climate change stuff like
jobs in the tobacco company we were just
like shut the [ __ ] up
right shut up shut up shut up shut up
because the deaths were very provable
so that's my take on it i
i i wish them health i don't not like
[ __ ]
get off my property i just i wish them
health
and i think if they were more
uh disciplined with their self
they'd be they'd be uh we'd all be in
better shape
now literally yeah we'd be better but
like and i'm very disciplined and that's
what kind of what people don't like
about me whether they realize it or not
hey keith all right i heard keith crying
i did too hey buddy
[Music]
yeah he really did he gets stuck on him
goodbye hey guys wondering why we
haven't truly embraced the double-blind
experiment process in our justice system
couldn't we fix our racially and
economically biased
system by just putting everyone in
separate rooms
using type to talk apps and redacting
other irrelevant info
sounds like the only problem
might be that juries and judges uh would
be more dispassionate with their
sentences
to which every black person america
would chuckle and reenact the kermit
sipping the t
meme i'm pretty sure the rich would
eventually find a workaround but
short term it would motivate the system
to create a pro
appropriate sentencing for everybody and
it's better than what we currently have
absolutely
yeah like it's absolutely you shouldn't
even know the you shouldn't know the
gender
you shouldn't know the race you should
you should know the circumstances
and the crime or the alleged crime
um but like yeah it's all
it's the whole thing is corrupt yeah
once you know about by
like human bias it's like okay well so
we'll go
they should have gone from the study
about bias
to the courthouse like okay well this
doesn't work so we need to redesign this
but it's
it's the i never thought about has
anybody proposed double blind
uh well i don't know what double
means in this case i don't either but i
just mean blind um
[Music]
i don't know i feel like sweden probably
thought about it
right how do you think
i guess it's howdy yeah it's like uh
the defendant a yeah you just don't say
their name
you don't say anything that can alert to
no he she they
no potato head potato head then potato
had entered the store
and take took out his potato gun
and shot miss
no potato head b in
the eye of the potato
you got it guys for example
goodbye recently i was listening to the
podcast i was hearing both of you speak
about countries or states like texas
with little government intervention
oh this is a good apology this is a neil
go apologize come on
um the argument was quite solid it was
about
uh a republican's view of small
government the argument was quite solid
when you
highlighted how countries with no
government involvement
in the lives of the citizens tend to
lack adequate investment infrastructure
and generally good quality of life uh
but when neil said
you want to see small government go to
rwanda i couldn't help to think
how bad of an example that was rwanda's
government is extremely large
and concerned in comparison to other
countries with similar population size
and involved in people's lives the
government is
and uh as it heavily spends in
government programs
and public infrastructure from roads to
public housing
to schools it's to the point that the
government created a day called
umaganda or national cleanup day which
makes all citizens clean up their
cities and towns the last saturday of
each month
to make rwanda the cleanest and most
well-paved country
in africa they're boy totally
contradicting your point
about the government being strong
because they make the people do it
um i have a great cleaning lady she
makes you clean the house up yourself
the rwandan government is also quite
strict and at times politically
repressive but two things it is
presently not
uh which are small and uninvolved i love
the podcast and both of you are very
knowledgeable
but i just think choosing the country
which seems to be the first presumably
[ __ ] up country
that came to mind for neil continues the
all too familiar and
inaccurately generally generalized
perspectives about africa
and structures in this highly diverse
continent yes signed trevor
noah what uh yes
but in our defense we went you went for
rwanda because of the genocide in the
90s i went yeah right
i went for rwanda i actually thought
about when i read this letter why i went
to rwanda
because i had ghana on my mind gonna oh
my
god um
and nigeria it's got that word in it
so i just like let me not let me stay
away from it
and which leaves chad chad of course who
sounds like a
a guy and like there's it's not an easy
it's not a dunk
and then there's north africa like you
know again
i hear you but also i hear myself
right um no he's got a good point i just
mean
the funny that the cleaning yourself
cleaning self-service is not a good
government policy
if you're trying to show how great the
government is um
uh yes so so there you go everybody when
you're done with ghana
keep on walking to rwanda
bring a broom it's on the other side of
the country from goodbye
you've got hello and bianca thanks for
the podcast new active listener
you guys are great down to business i
grew up with a lot of verbal emotional
abuse
i grew up in a lower middle class home
uh
upwardly mobile i'm one of three girls
each of us two years apart born in 69 71
and 73.
my father was a drunk and a bully to all
of us my mom included
he's still a bully and mom is still with
him he treats her like garbage
i've recently decided not to see them
anymore but still feel intense guilt
they didn't beat up or starve me but i
feel like garbage when i'm around them
i can't explain why but being around
them makes me feel pretty sick
despite a lot of abuse all three of us
kids did well and surpassed their
parents academically and professionally
with zero guilt
i'm sorry with zero parental support we
still all have issues though my siblings
make me feel very guilty for
hanging on to past abuse and grudges
again against my parents so it's very
hard
to interact with them also and i'd
rather not
is it okay to completely leave your
family of origin behind
and not look back why do i feel such
intense guilt about doing it very
conflicted
can't think of a cute way to end this
that was it the first
step is admitting that you can't think
of a cute way to end the email
uh i've been pretty clear about this yes
self-care number one uh
and then everybody else number two
so if it's just not healthy for you
don't do it and just say i don't it i'm
it's not healthy for me
yeah and without even the expectation
that they're going to come back
having learned or answered should be
like this isn't healthy
that's not a good way to talk to people
i don't like that tone
but that's what families do is they just
everybody regresses
yeah um you're you have a dip you have a
more panamanian take on this
the middle east and panamania no i i
just
i don't know we've talked about it a
bunch before but
i think it'd be very hard for me to cut
off my family even though
they wreck my head a lot uh
i just have bad i think i grew up with a
bad sense of boundaries between people
friends family i don't have you and your
mom feel like
friends more you feel more like
girlfriends no i
like i'm like her parent okay
so that we have attention because i
tend to over like police what she's
doing a lot
and uh she's doesn't like it obviously
yeah so we have our own special
yeah yeah so it's the roles are a little
bit reversed there but
um i think my issue that i've realized
is
and i've said it before growing up i
thought not having boundaries and being
able to take it with
was strength like i can handle
anything well that's the thing that they
trick you into thinking yeah and it's
actually weakness because saying to
someone hey you i don't like the way you
make me feel
and i need to take a step back way
harder scarier
uncut more uncomfortable to do that
that's really
in my opinion now that's the strength
the strength is
if you really want to be a strong minded
person and and
um consider yourself like oh i can
handle anything like then handle
boundaries because
that shit's scary yeah so i would say
start your journey and start just
getting familiar with like what your
boundaries are
because sometimes you don't realize you
needed certain boundaries or you didn't
think it was possible to have boundaries
with
family because they're your family and
it's like
you're not allowed you're not really
allowed to say like
no not today i you didn't you know
whatever you're voting for the
thing is an exercise and a lack of
boundaries like we're all in the same
house
i have the key to your house right no
open your door
it's just yeah it's so i think you have
to start
they start the relationship with your
boundaries and understand where they are
because that took me a really long time
to understand
like oh i don't like like i it almost
reminds me of i've never liked sweets
even as a kid and i think i went to
somebody's house
when i was in the seventh grade one
friend of mine and i was like oh do you
have any soda or juice
she's like oh we don't drink that i
don't like sweets and it blew my mind
that i didn't have to drink soda
and i thought to myself i [ __ ] hate
soda but i didn't know i had the option
not to drink wait you didn't
know you didn't have the option when you
went to the other person's house
no in life we give kids soda so much
yeah like it's just like soda juice and
i
wasn't aware as a kid that you could
just say
i don't like this i don't want hawaiian
punch
like i don't want hi-c yeah i don't want
to
ecto cooler even though those are
delicious like i don't want this [ __ ]
and i
always was like if they make you drink
it kids say they molested you
it's the best make a documentary saying
that they will listen
and i will defend the doc somebody
somebody
said the wrong person probably um
so yeah just your boundaries are good
boundaries boundaries are good
there's a problem down the line which i
have which is when when does a boundary
become a wall
but oh that's interesting so when have
you felt your boundaries have become
i was used to be very codependent and
have no boundaries
and then i overcompensated for by having
strict boundaries and strict rules and
if you can believe it wow uh it's strict
like why do i
get mad a long time ago but is there a
way to
come meet in the middle somebody made
the observation that
it's a boundary is a wall with
doors yeah so
you know but how do you go from not
being like
with your with your rules uh
you just you feel it out what is
what is uh have you worked on it i feel
like you still need
to work on them well that's between you
you just crossed a boundary
i'm sorry uh so
guess who i guess is working on it now
you are dear goodbye you've got i am one
of those people you described who's
against dalia
uh he probably can't ever win me back
did you ever did you notice in dalia's
video that he didn't mention any of the
reasons why people were mad at him
uh no one was upset that he was hooking
up with his adult fans
he wasn't cancelled because he cheated
on his fiance it was the flashing
coercion and inappropriate interactions
with underage girls
that upset everyone he didn't mention
any of that in the video
not even to deny it deleo saying all my
hookups were consensual and legal
was the closest he came to acknowledging
the actual reason he was canceled
the rest of video was just
self-flagellation for a sex addiction no
one cared about
like neil said most guys would message
tons of women if they were in delia's
position
and as a woman i'd argue that most women
wouldn't care
seemed odd to me that neither of you
guys mentioned how delia's video was an
attempt to change the narrative from
man who grooms teen girls to man
suffering from sex addiction any
thoughts on that
bianca you have a lot to do i mean i'll
i can respond to this
i don't think in both responses i don't
think he groomed teen girls
oh i don't know about all that i don't
know i just don't think he groomed teen
girls i don't think that there's proof
of him grooming teen girls and i don't
i think that when he said it was legal
and consensual
i think the girls that he messaged the
minute he knew they were underage he
stopped messaging them
so that's what i saw but i i think i saw
the same thing i saw him
respond to oh you're not legal okay
whatever but
i don't think that's the point i think
it's let's just say
his opinion was i didn't groom anybody
like say
like hey i got canceled for x reason
i didn't do these things like at least
i think what everyone is saying and i
heard this after we talked about it and
it made me think
was we go oh my god
he doesn't like us talking about delay
what it hey go go
go what if there's an earthquake and
he's sensing it that would be so great
for the podcast
go go what are you feeling good buddy
go keep going going oh no sorry
did the wrong thing go the wrong way
go no no no
go buddy go go go
good boy good boy good boy all right
okay um so let's just regardless of what
you think he did right let's just talk
about the actual video
he did they're right like he didn't
really address much
he said he's cheated and
he did say stuff about like having like
i i've only had consent
consensual sex yeah
so he didn't really just like attack
head on
the allegations or the things that got
him canceled do you think
if you're gonna make a video after all
this time
maybe it would have been
more fruitful to just attack the
elephant in the room because i do feel
like there was still an elephant when he
after the video you know it's not like
he didn't yeah i just thought he covered
it
that i thought when he by saying legal
and consensual right
and that they released
his lawyer somebody released uh the
proof
of the him going no thank you why not
say
i didn't do the things that i didn't
groom anybody i didn't do
if you like why not because this is
where it gets into this emotional
thing of like well i wanted it's like
the guy's been in the penalty box for a
year
he lost a lot they're they're also gonna
he didn't lose anything he's already
lost a lot
right right so i just
feel like everyone wants these a la
carte or or like
uh
they want they want uh apologies to
to their specifications you know
but if you are accused of something
isn't it
isn't it better to say if you're like i
didn't do this [ __ ] isn't it better to
not talk about what's going with you but
just at least
clear-cut say i did not do this
at all i did not groom any but like
because they there's specific
words attached to it right so why not
just hit them and be like
i i partially it's i'm sure a lawyer
told him
like don't say this
you may want to say stay in this area
stay out of that area i don't know if
that's
applicable to this but that's when we
were talking about it's like how does
someone just take it away from julia
because i'm just asking like just all
the questions what do you do in this
situation you know yeah
so let's just take away from him what do
you do when you're
you're saying i'm innocent and these
allegations
and the court of public opinion has
already
made you guilty do you go
after it do you say really plainly like
i didn't do any of these things or do
you just kind of
say your peace with it and not have to
do
this dance or i don't know like i'm just
trying to understand what's the
right way to go about it because this
person's saying he should have said
he should have attacked the allegations
head-on
the what he was accused of is is
illegal and non-consensual right so the
exposing himself
um and the
grooming and the other one
underage girls right are all
either illegal or not consensual right
and by saying i don't i didn't do that
i think i it didn't bother me
in terms of like he's not talking about
because i just
that's that's under that umbrella yeah
but it's
you know it's uh the bespoke apology is
what i was
looking for the term i was looking for
dan harmon
had a good one a couple years ago that
you know have you listened to his
apology album
it's pretty good uh but he but his was
vaguer and more personal it was like
psychological with a writer female
writer under
power dynamics and all kinds of [ __ ]
his that's why his was good because the
charges were like
vague and he was pretty openly
apolog like he seemed completely
apologetic
i thought chris was apologetic i didn't
it didn't feel staged or like
um like i don't think that was
take three do you know what i mean uh it
just seemed like that's how he felt and
uh
but i think it's a matter of it's it's
it's uh bringing
legalese to an emotions fight he's
bringing legalese to a thing where
he needs to project sorrow
and contrition i'll give you that it
wasn't
that much contrition like in terms of
like
emotion like in terms of like what did
you like acting class like okay what did
he what was he giving us there like
he wasn't like over it was kind of like
more than i
usually that i've seen him give but
uh but i personally don't have that
problem because all the things she
mentioned
fell under that to me when peop so let's
just in general when people do get
canceled like this
do you think it's better to just
disappear and not say anything
or do you think it's better to like
attack it head-on because
louie's touring you know it's only a
couture
you think you could do it yeah and not
have like many issues
i mean if louie didn't he won't right
you just go you just you just the places
aren't as big
you know that's it and
they're all dues
that's the other thing it's just no dude
no women um
uh even serial killers get no of course
there's like that
the rich ramirez he should dress like he
should have a pentagram on his hand if
you'd go out if you go back out chris
um so i think you are
i don't know i think you're just
wondering i think dan harmon's was the
best one because he
actually sounded uh
considerate more than anybody yeah i
didn't
it wasn't it wasn't
you know it just i don't know it just
aziz and
chris's and louise and they've all kind
of done it in different ways
i'm trying to think okay if you've ever
ow if you as a
someone that you know we've all been in
had our opinion
about someone from afar like we've all
been part of the jury of
public opinion what do you want to hear
like i'm just thinking of a
racist whatever karen type
but there are now it's all so pre
it's also prescribed of like say this
right
do i want to do it yeah it's i the
people who are like
you [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] recorded
i don't care who sees this and it's like
i
never meant to hurt what came over me
anybody yeah
and i'm talking about this i'm not
talking about chris i'm just saying
that's
when i think of those people apologizing
i think it's
the feeling you [ __ ] i think
it's the feeling
what feeling are you giving me that's it
like that's it aziz gave a lot of
contrition
and to which people
of varying degrees are like why is
what's he confronted about
that's a whole other issue but yeah um
it's a matter of contrition and
the other thing is kids yeah meaning
all these guys have kids and the thing
that
impedes maverick
uh uh uh
behavior is knowing that your kid can
pay the price for it
so kid chris obviously being
a new a new dad is probably like like i
need to
provide and so people are like they
should have gone on it's like they don't
you know aziz doesn't have kids
but um aziz wanted to be accepted back
in
the winner's circle right as you know i
just it's
i feel like we're in the wild west of
like what do you do when you're on the
other side of things i mean
it's you know do you
just say well i had a good run because
entertainment is so reputation based
it's not like
he's getting chased out of california
you know it's just it's
based so i i don't know it's weird it's
just a weird
beast like what to do with your
reputation how to repair it
is it is there some reputations that are
beyond is can you
or also we also forget [ __ ] very quickly
as people you gotta you gotta hit you
gotta bob
uh yeah i don't there's no dan harmon's
was good
but there's no real uh
good clear way to do it
um sit buddy sit sit
sit ready set
okay you're talking to will or
keith or kevin hart
um goodbye you've got mail
one what do you want one more yeah uh
what's going on y'all been listening
since day one
um i'm 26 year old blackmail in a
relationship with 26 year old white
woman the other night we had a
discussion about rachel dolezal not
being able to get hired did we read this
um she was discovered not no actually
being black i told my girlfriend that as
a black person
uh i wouldn't take a course about
african
or african american studies taught by a
person that wasn't black
she thought that this was closed-minded
to me and i was completely confused by
that
what do you guys think appreciate y'all
take care this is similar to
gay people should only play gay people
if there's a
captivating white person
or latin person or whatever who can
knows
african-american history really well and
can teach it really well
than a less than optimal
black teacher what do you mean less than
optimal blacks
they're just the worst teacher or
maybe there's not persuasive or no i'm
saying like literally a b
okay african-american studies
white woman who's
very charismatic very knowledgeable very
just
that sh [ __ ] is open and just a good
teacher
and a black person same
accreditation in terms of education
not as good a teacher i
don't know that's a tough one right but
it's
it i don't think it's open and shut i
don't think it's like you gotta go with
the blind
if you can still take the lessons that
the white person tells you
i i don't know i've had a lot of college
professors
and sometimes even if you read on like
ratemyprofessor.com or whatever the [ __ ]
it is now uh sometimes you just
i've had bad teachers that i've gleaned
plenty from that weren't that persuasive
i don't know i think i would prefer
right but i don't but they have the same
knowledge no no i understand but there's
some
sort there's some african-american
history
the black woman's gonna have knowledge a
white person doesn't have it all
obviously
right so i don't that's what there's an
ad i mean if we're going to get into
history if you're talking about like
history
up until the time they're both born
let's say their
history up to black history civil rights
movement
neither one of them were alive right
right
i don't i to me obviously i'm biased
because
i'm uh
i i've said [ __ ] that ended up in black
people's act
yeah that was
based on a historic thing that they
didn't you know what i mean like so i
don't
i don't think that it's worse
once the person has the knowledge who
gives a [ __ ] where they got it i
okay so for example in there's a few
classes
a german class and a french class maybe
it's a little different
but i had two particular teachers that
were american
and i they were worse teachers
that's a different i know it's different
but they they they knew they were
exactly proficient in french than
any other teacher than and in german
than all of my other teachers the
american woman was the head of the
german department but still
i got much fear go ahead i got much more
from
the german teacher and not because you
know pronunciation or technically no i
didn't get
much more but they
taught with the familiarity that the
american person couldn't
so i have to kind of use that as a
measure i feel like that's a
different thing if you're teaching a
language
but if you're black and teaching
african-american history and you can
maybe like
i don't know like uh tie it in
yeah so what that's that's what is
different because it's not that
it's not that the american my friend you
know it's not like they taught me
incorrect german and it's actually a
better example because
there's only one way to teach german
regardless of who you are you know what
i mean like
it's either like d deridas and it and
those are rules that are already set
so regardless of it's you a mere german
person if
you know there's only one way to do it
so if someone is
black and teaching afro-american history
i feel like
i would prefer to get it from a black
person i don't know i i
of course like you prefer you know what
i mean like
it's like feels better but what i'm
saying is
if they're not as good a speaker
or what if there's [ __ ] about them that
makes them a worse i don't even remember
the problem but the problem is you're
making the black one
worse so if they're all the same yeah go
to the black one but there's nothing
about this was that
there was a white you know you're you're
kind of hacking
the scene i told my everyone that i was
as my friend wouldn't take a course
about black or african-american studies
taught by a person that wasn't black
right he wouldn't take the class i know
what i'm saying is that you're hacking
it
into one is a worse option and one is a
better option so it's like
no i'm saying if you he's
if i'm saying like one is white or you
don't take the class and he's going
okay let's do that one is why that's
what he's saying
yes i know but that's not what you were
saying oh yeah but i'm so
the next logical thing is does a person
who's teaching about that thing have to
be that thing
i think it's
there and depending on what uh
study it's better when they are if i had
to take a class
and you're the only professor that's
teaching it obviously i'm going to take
the class thank you
you know i was like can i just play his
reel of saying
class is full the n-word
um so yeah i don't know so so there we
go we solved
racism solved it uh we'll save that one
for next week guys
what a podcast we were both i think
very good daniel came by we had a
guest we had a guest thank you i tried
to get another guest
and he didn't can we have a fa one of
your famous friends every
other pod uh
no okay i was trying to get arsenio to
come talk about
coming to america but i love arsenio
text me back
um now's the time
go go go you can play the musical um
uh we don't have to take this [ __ ] we
don't thank you bye goodbye
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]